Hi, this is Joel Blackstock with the Taproot Therapy Collective podcast, and today we have an article about architecture that I'm going to read that is called Frank Lloyd Wrong, Why We Didn't Take the Right Lessons from Frank Lloyd Wright's Legacy. If you want to look at the article on our blog, in addition to listening to it on the podcast, there are some photographs that go along with it, which make it a little bit easier to see. And so I will begin that article now. So I mentioned Frank Lloyd Wright quite a bit on the blog.
大家好，我是Taproot Therapy Collective播客的乔尔·布莱克斯托克（Joel Blackstock）。今天我们要读一篇关于建筑的文章，题目是《弗兰克·劳埃德·错：为什么我们没有从弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特的遗产中吸取正确的教训》。如果你想在我们的博客上阅读这篇文章，除了收听播客之外，文中还配有一些照片，这会让理解变得更容易一些。那么，我现在就开始读这篇文章。我在博客里提到过弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特很多次。
We talk about design and the psychology of design and architecture and psychology in different parts of life. A lot of people have asked why. What is it that they see him, I guess, as kind of dated to lump him in with all of the modernist architects that have flat roofs. So what is it that I see in Wright's work? Why do I think that he is interesting? And the answer is I think his process is a little bit more interesting than all of his designs. Because I think design is always a work in progress.
我们谈论过设计、设计心理学，以及生活不同层面的建筑与心理学。很多人问我为什么。我想，他们之所以觉得他有点过时，是因为把他和所有那些拥有平屋顶的现代主义建筑师归为了一类。那么，我在赖特的作品中看到了什么？为什么我觉得他很有趣？答案是，我认为他的过程比他所有的设计都要有趣得多。因为我认为设计永远是一个正在进行中的工作。
Or design is always an imperfect process. It's more about finding the way that you do it, not just making the perfect design. Now there's hard answers and there's soft answers in psychology. And so hard answers are objective things like, penicillin cures this infection or this randomized controlled trial shows that this thing works best on this kind of patient for this diagnosis. Soft answers are going to be more subjective and they're going to be less testable.
或者说，设计永远是一个不完美的过程。它更多的是关于找到你做事的方法，而不仅仅是做出完美的设计。在心理学中，有“硬答案”和“软答案”。硬答案是客观的东西，比如“青霉素可以治愈这种感染”，或者“这项随机对照试验表明，这种方法对这类患者的这种诊断效果最好”。软答案则更具主观性，也更难进行测试。
So when Bessel van der Kolk says something like, you know, neuroscience research shows that the only way that we can change the way we feel is by becoming aware of our inner experience and learning to befriend what is going on inside ourselves. It makes sense that he's saying that we have to acknowledge all the parts of us. We have to experience those parts. We have to deconstruct ourself into a series of parts. And we have to realize that we are all of those parts, not just the ones that we like and kind of reidentify. Like we can intuitively understand that, but we can't do a test to say, is this right or wrong? There's not a way to do a randomized controlled trial
所以，当贝塞尔·范德考克（Bessel van der Kolk）说类似“神经科学研究表明，我们改变感受的唯一途径是意识到我们的内在体验，并学会与我们内心的感受和解”这样的话时，他是在说我们必须承认我们所有的部分。我们必须体验这些部分。我们必须将自己解构为一系列的部分。我们必须意识到我们就是所有这些部分的总和，而不仅仅是我们喜欢并重新认同的那部分。就像我们可以直观地理解这一点，但我们无法通过测试来判断它是对还是错。没有办法进行随机对照试验
about that. Yet we know what it means. It's a soft answer. And so, you know, with soft sciences, you're always in the process of trying to get it right, but it's never quite done, you know. And art is never done, goes the quote. You know, it just stops in nice places.
来验证这一点。然而我们知道它意味着什么。这是一个软答案。所以，你知道，在软科学中，你总是处于试图把它做对的过程中，但它永远不会真正完成。你知道，正如那句名言所说，艺术永远不会完成，它只是停在了美好的地方。
I think Da Vinci said that. And so it might've been Michelangangelo um please don't uh email me um but design is something that will always be us off science you know we'll never build the perfect house or create the definitive couch that never needs any further iteration design is always kind of trying to meld process style meet the limitations of any point in economics and society and manufacturing. And in doing that, it's never done. You don't just say, okay, we did the perfect one. Now let's try and design something else. It's always changing. And so it's probably easier to say what Frank Lloyd Wright was not than what he was. He was not a very good guy. Despite his
我想这是达芬奇说的。也可能是米开朗基罗，请不要给我发邮件。但设计是一门永远的软科学，你知道，我们永远不会建造出完美的房子，也不会创造出永远不需要迭代的终极沙发。设计总是试图融合过程、风格，并满足经济、社会和制造方面的任何限制。正因如此，它永远不会完成。你不能只是说：“好了，我们做出了完美的作品，现在让我们去设计别的东西吧。”它总是在变化。所以，说弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特“不是什么”可能比说他“是什么”更容易。他并不是一个好人。尽管他
talent as an architect, Wright was erratic and just indefensible as a person. He was a narcissist. He was a serial adulterer. He was a liar. He's been called a compulsive liar before. I'm going to say no. He was just a liar because when you are a compulsive liar, you lie about things that do not benefit you. And most of Wright's lies were to get what he wanted. He would lie about the value of art, or he would lie about, you know, when the Frank Lloyd Wright's building in Japan was not demolished
作为建筑师很有才华，但赖特性格反复无常，作为一个人简直无可辩驳。他是个自恋者。他是个连环通奸者。他是个骗子。他以前被称为强迫性撒谎者。我要说不，他只是个骗子，因为当你是一个强迫性撒谎者时，你会对那些对你没有好处的事情撒谎。而赖特的大多数谎言都是为了得到他想要的东西。他会谎报艺术的价值，或者他会谎称，你知道，当弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特在日本的建筑没有被拆毁时
during the earthquake that happened. He went to everybody and was like, my building was the only one that didn't fall down. Well, most of the buildings didn't fall down. But so anyway, most of the things were in service of narcissism. I don't think he was a compulsive liar, but he definitely did not have a problem lying. He was a mean spirit and just kind of an inveterate overspender. He exploited his workers. He's just not a good guy. So that's not why I look up to him or not look up to him, but that's not why I admire his process. I don't look up to him. So many times a person's biography shows clues as to why they have this kind of disordered personality and what they're compensating for.
在地震发生期间。他跑去告诉所有人：“我的建筑是唯一没有倒塌的。”好吧，其实大多数建筑都没有倒塌。但总之，大多数事情都是为了服务于他的自恋。我不认为他是一个强迫性撒谎者，但他确实不介意撒谎。他心地刻薄，而且是一个根深蒂固的挥霍者。他剥削他的工人。他真的不是个好人。所以，我并不是因为这些而仰慕他，或者说不仰慕他，但我钦佩他的过程。我并不崇拜他。很多时候，一个人的传记会显示出他们为什么会有这种混乱的人格，以及他们在补偿什么。
Wright's biography doesn't really give you a reason for him to be the way that he was. I mean, I think he was just brilliant, and he was prophetically influential. A ton was wrong with the kind of artistic and industrial assumptions of the time, and he knew he was right. He had a massive superiority complex. He knew that he was seeing the future and he didn't mind humiliating people
赖特的传记并没有真正给出他为什么会成为那样的人的理由。我的意思是，我认为他只是才华横溢，而且具有预言性的影响力。当时那种艺术和工业假设中有很多错误，而他知道自己是对的。他有一种巨大的优越感。他知道自己看到了未来，他不介意羞辱别人
and telling them that. And so he never really integrated any of his gifts as an artist into a coherent or healthy psyche. He did experience tragedy as an adult. You know, his wife and his children or her child, he married one of his client's wives at one point, and she left her husband, and she was murdered, along with her children and some of his staff at Tally's in his home. But that's pretty late in life. I mean, he was kind of a bad guy before that, so I'm sure that didn't make, you know, that was definitely traumatic for him.
并告诉他们这一点。所以他从未真正将他作为艺术家的天赋整合到一个连贯或健康的心理中。他在成年后确实经历过悲剧。你知道，他的妻子和孩子，或者她的孩子——他曾娶过一位客户的妻子，她离开了丈夫，后来她和她的孩子们以及他的一些员工在塔里埃森（Taliesin）的家中被谋杀。但这发生在他生命的后期。我的意思是，他在那之前就已经是个坏人了，所以我肯定那并没有让他……你知道，那对他来说绝对是创伤性的。
But I don't know that that explains anything like some people try and and do and right also just isn't always a perfect architect like i don't love everything he did um he tries a lot which i think is better than just kind of doing the same thing forever he definitely is like always wrestling with um new ideas and and how to move on to the next thing but some of his revival periods are just really cold and they move away from his original ideas of form before, you know, he puts form before function in some designs, I think, in the service of experimentation that doesn't really pay off, even though that goes against his own principles. And so what makes him a mandatory design reference point to me,
但我不知道这是否能解释什么，就像有些人试图做的那样。而且赖特也并不总是一个完美的建筑师，我不喜欢他做的一切。他尝试了很多，我认为这比永远只做同样的事情要好。他绝对总是像在与新想法搏斗，以及如何进入下一阶段，但他的一些复兴时期作品真的很冷漠，它们偏离了他之前关于形式的原始想法。你知道，我认为在某些设计中，他把形式置于功能之上，这是为了服务于那些并没有真正奏效的实验，尽管这违背了他自己的原则。所以，对我来说，是什么让他成为了一个必不可少的参考点，
why you have to talk about him even if you don't like him when you're talking about design and style not just in architecture is it's kind of a soft answer um he was able to pull a ton of things together and articulate what architecture was in a way that i don't think had been done before um if it was done before it was done by you know somebody like h Arendt or philosophers, not architects. They were talking about the nature of art, but he did it as a professional, not as a philosopher. I had a college professor who told me one time that reading works in translation is like making love through a plate glass window. He was talking about reading Latin and Greek and that you really, unless you speak Latin and ancient Greek, you don't really get the
为什么当你谈论设计和风格（不仅仅是在建筑领域）时，即使你不喜欢他，也必须谈论他，是因为这是一种“软答案”。他能够将大量事物整合在一起，并以一种我认为以前从未有过的方式阐述什么是建筑。如果以前有人这样做过，那也是像汉娜·阿伦特（H. Arendt）这样的哲学家，而不是建筑师。他们谈论的是艺术的本质，但他是以专业人士的身份，而不是以哲学家的身份做到的。我的一位大学教授曾经告诉我，阅读翻译作品就像隔着玻璃窗做爱。他当时是在谈论阅读拉丁语和希腊语，说除非你会说拉丁语和古希腊语，否则你真的无法体会
feel for what the Odyssey, how beautiful the writing is. And architecture is kind of the same way. There's some photos on the blog, there's some visual tours of his stuff, but really, you just go into his spaces, you feel something. That is what I'm describing. You feel something that he says over and over, what the point of architecture is and what he wants you to feel. And I'll talk a little bit about what that is, but a big part of what it is is I think
《奥德赛》那种写作的美感。建筑也是如此。博客上有一些照片，有一些关于他作品的视觉导览，但实际上，你必须走进他的空间，你才能感受到某种东西。这就是我所描述的。你感受到了他反复强调的建筑的意义，以及他希望你感受到的东西。我会稍微谈谈那是什么，但我认为其中很大一部分是
he makes the structure a node between our humanity, the way we use a space, you know, practically what we need, the natural world around it, which is why none of his buildings in different places are the same. He matches the natural world and the site. He would contemplate this a whole lot. And then thirdly, a sort of elevated spiritual idea of the purpose of the building so there's a practical purpose
他使建筑成为了我们的人性、我们使用空间的方式（你知道，实际上我们需要什么）、它周围的自然世界之间的一个节点，这就是为什么他在不同地方的建筑没有一个是相同的。他将自然世界与场地相匹配。他会对此进行大量的思考。然后第三点，一种关于建筑目的的提升了的精神理念。所以有一个实际的目的，
more of like a subjective spiritual um higher purpose and then there's the natural world and so these things intersecting was what he tried to feel, and I think that's really neat. He called his architecture organic architecture. And so he believed that the building should emerge naturally from their surrounding and blend seamlessly with the environment around it. You look at a poem like Wallace Stevens, The Anecdote of the Jar, that when you put something in a place, that thing changes the place you put it that thing changes the place you put it in and the place you put it in changes the thing because they're in conversation with each other and wright was really into that um he sought to enhance the beauty of the site and to participate in the beauty he he was viewing it like he already had a painting the nature was the painting and he had to make a change to it so he's going to be respectful he wasn't just going to come to a picture of a landscape and then all of a sudden
更多的是一种主观的精神上的更高目的，然后是自然世界。所以这些事物的交集就是他试图去感受的东西，我认为这真的很棒。他称他的建筑为“有机建筑”。因此，他认为建筑应该自然地从周围环境中生长出来，并与周围的环境无缝融合。你看看华莱士·史蒂文斯（Wallace Stevens）的诗《罐子的轶事》（The Anecdote of the Jar），当你把某样东西放在一个地方时，那个东西改变了你放置它的地方，而你放置它的地方也改变了那个东西，因为它们在彼此对话。赖特真的很喜欢这一点。他试图增强场地的美感，并参与到这种美中。他看待它的方式就像他已经拥有了一幅画，自然就是那幅画，而他必须对其做出改变。所以他会很尊重，他不会只是来到一幅风景画前，然后突然
you know paint uh spray paint graffiti on it he was going to try and make the thing he was adding to it part of it in a way that a lot of architects didn't do at the time or they saw the point of architecture as beating back or taming overcoming nature nature, not really conversing with it. And so his designs, they often feature like horizontal lines and angles that mimic horizons. He would kind of echo the ripples, curves, peaks, whatever the surrounding geography was in the structure. And then he would use local materials that looked like they came from the site or did come from the site, like wood and stone and try and keep paint the same colors as what things would be at different times of year. I mean, he would look at these buildings sometimes,
你知道，喷漆涂鸦。他会试图让他添加的东西成为它的一部分，这在当时很多建筑师并没有这样做，或者他们认为建筑的意义在于击退、驯服或克服自然，而不是真正与它对话。所以他的设计经常以模仿地平线的水平线条和角度为特色。他会用结构来呼应周围地理环境的涟漪、曲线、山峰等。然后他会使用看起来像是来自现场，或者确实来自现场的当地材料，比如木头和石头，并试图让油漆保持与一年中不同时间事物相同的颜色。我的意思是，他有时会观察这些建筑，
the sites for the buildings, you know, for a year or two years before he built something, because you know, he wanted it to work in the winter too. He wanted it, you know, it was talking to seasons. You know, just incredibly complex ability to listen to detail in a way that I think is very mindful and interesting in his, you know, professional life, something he never was able to do personally. He was not a mindful person. He was always in debt. He was always having affairs. He was always having fights. But he was able to do this professionally. And so, you know, for right form followed function, meaning that you built the thing to be useful.
观察建筑场地，你知道，在建造之前观察一两年，因为你知道，他希望它在冬天也能发挥作用。他希望它，你知道，它是在与季节对话。你知道，这种极其复杂的倾听细节的能力，我认为在他的职业生涯中是非常专注和有趣的，这是他在个人生活中从未做到过的。他不是一个专注的人。他总是负债累累。他总是搞婚外情。他总是吵架。但他能在职业生涯中做到这一点。所以，你知道，对赖特来说，形式追随功能，意味着你建造这个东西是为了实用。
And then you once you had the usefulness, you made it pretty. You didn't just do what we think design is now, I think, too much where we just make something cool looking and then say, OK, well, that's neat and that great because it looks good, but it doesn't work as a house. It doesn't work as a phone. It doesn't work as a toaster. It's designed to be stylish, not to do its job. And Wright believed that function was the point of architecture.
然后一旦你有了实用性，你就让它变得漂亮。你不会只做我们现在认为的设计——我认为现在太多了——我们只是让东西看起来很酷，然后说：“好吧，这很整洁，这很棒，因为它看起来不错，但它作为房子并不好用。它作为手机不好用。它作为烤面包机不好用。”它是为了时尚而设计的，而不是为了完成它的工作。而赖特认为功能才是建筑的重点。
You were figuring out how people lived. You were observing them. Not just nature. He would observe these families. I mean, sometimes he'd go to their house and he would take tapes and he would watch them and he would see how they cooked dinner and what they ate and where they walked to build something that may enhance their routine practically. And then also was a part of nature.
你是在弄清楚人们是如何生活的。你在观察他们。不仅仅是自然。他会观察这些家庭。我的意思是，有时他会去他们家，他会录音，他会观察他们，他会看他们如何做晚饭，他们吃什么，他们走到哪里，从而建造出能够实际增强他们日常生活的建筑。然后它也是自然的一部分。
And then thirdly, enhanced their routine spiritually, which is my next point. So not just does he matching the way that the form followed the function of what the space was for materially and practically he also kind of would would echo greater cultures you'd religious themes he would take um these patterns that i think are really neat and he would infuse the structures with these repetitive motifs that created this sense of continuity and coherence because they happen on a big scale a middle medium scale and a teeny tiny small scale. Sometimes the carvings are so intricate and even if you don't notice it intellectually, you're feeling that pattern kind of ripple from the outside when you're walking up
然后第三点，在精神上增强他们的日常生活，这是我的下一个观点。所以，他不仅在形式上追随了空间在物质和实际上的功能，他还会在某种程度上呼应更伟大的文化，即宗教主题。他会采用这些我认为非常棒的图案，并将这些重复的母题注入到结构中，创造出一种连续性和连贯感，因为它们发生在宏观、中观和微观的尺度上。有时雕刻非常复杂，即使你在理智上没有注意到它，当你走近时，你也会感觉到那种图案从外面
to the building, to the inside when you're looking at the structure of the windows, to the teeny tiny cuts on the grates. They all sort of flow together. They're a pattern that is starting very big and then becoming very small. And a lot of them had a lot of symbolism and meaning. You know, sometimes he documented that in the plans and would tell you that this represented, you know, this Indian tribe's belief or this land or this thing. And then other times we don't really know what he, there was meaning there, but it wasn't, it was his, it wasn't something that he said what it was. And so one of the things that's really interesting to me about Wright's spaces is he didn't really design them. Like he was an architect. Um, you know, we think about the person who takes out a blank sheet of paper and starts drawing this big, pretty thing. Um, or if you
一直涟漪到建筑内部，当你看着窗户的结构时，再到格栅上细小的切口。它们都以某种方式流动在一起。它们是一种从非常大开始，然后变得非常小的图案。其中许多都有很多象征意义和含义。你知道，有时他在计划中记录了这一点，并会告诉你这代表了，你知道，这个印第安部落的信仰，或者这片土地，或者这个东西。而其他时候，我们并不真正知道他……那里有意义，但它不是……那是他自己的，不是他说出来是什么的东西。所以，赖特的空间对我来说非常有趣的一点是，他并没有真正“设计”它们。就像他是一位建筑师。嗯，你知道，我们想到的是那种拿出空白纸，开始画出这个又大又漂亮的东西的人。嗯，或者如果你
know any architects, maybe they take out a cocktail napkin and draw on it. You know, they're sort of always doing this. But Wright didn't do that. I mean, instead, he went and he listened to the space. He listened to the people. And then he listened to the kind of spiritual or metaphysical or higher purpose. The third point doesn't quite fit neatly into one word. It was a conversation with a practical purpose of people, what they needed the building for,
认识任何建筑师，也许他们会拿出一张鸡尾酒餐巾纸在上面画画。你知道，他们似乎总是这样。但赖特没有那样做。我的意思是，相反，他去倾听空间。他倾听人们。然后他倾听那种精神上的、形而上学的或更高的目的。第三点并不完全适合用一个词来概括。它是与人们的实际目的、他们需要建筑做什么的对话，
what the natural world was imposing on the space, and then thirdly, this sort of higher ideal. And what that higher ideal is, Wright never articulates perfectly, but he is adamant that that's something, that third thing is something that you need to be aspiring to fuse, not just with the natural world, not just with the structure, what is needed for people, but also with a higher ideal. And so, you know, what you want to call that, I don't know, but I think that's an interesting concept. So, you know, good design to me is always somebody who's actually willing to sit with all of these limitations that make design harder and then try and wrestle them together. It's pulling these things that are conflicting forces and limitations into each other in a way that is ingenious. And,
自然世界强加给空间的东西，然后第三点，这种更高的理想。而那种更高的理想是什么，赖特从未完美地阐述过，但他坚持认为那是某种东西，那第三样东西是你需要渴望去融合的，不仅仅是与自然世界，不仅仅是与结构，不仅仅是人们所需要的，还要与更高的理想融合。所以，你知道，你想怎么称呼它，我不知道，但我认为这是一个有趣的概念。所以，你知道，对我来说，好的设计总是那些真正愿意坐下来面对所有这些让设计变得更困难的限制，然后试图将它们整合在一起的人。它是以一种巧妙的方式将这些相互冲突的力量和限制拉到一起。而且，
you know, if you're following a fad or a trend, everything looks the same, or you know that, well, gun metal's in this year, so I'm going to throw out my wardrobe and just do this. You're not really thinking, you're just kind of following what you're told and that stuff will look dated very quickly. One of the reasons why Wright's buildings don't look dated, most of them, I think is because his design is kind of timeless. His process resulted in this timeless message you can still hear. And that started with him listening to something. He didn't just sit down with a blank page and say, I'm going to draw a building. It was really trying to hear the building as it was supposed to exist. And so, I mean, even though Wright was a raging narcissist that took a credit for a lot of things, some of them not true, he didn't really
你知道，如果你在追随一种时尚或潮流，一切看起来都一样，或者你知道，嗯，今年枪灰色很流行，所以我打算扔掉我的衣柜，只做这个。你并没有真正思考，你只是在跟随别人告诉你的东西，而那些东西很快就会过时。赖特的建筑之所以看起来不过时（我认为大多数是这样），原因之一是因为他的设计在某种程度上是永恒的。他的过程产生了一种你仍然可以听到的永恒信息。而这始于他倾听某样东西。他并没有只是坐在一张白纸前说：“我要画一栋建筑。”他真的是在试图倾听建筑本该存在的样子。所以，我的意思是，尽管赖特是一个狂暴的自恋者，为很多事情邀功，其中一些甚至不是真的，但他并没有真正
take credit for that design process. He saw it as this form of intuition that anyone could tap into and that more architects should tap into. And he thought, I think he, well, he says, you know, I'm better than everybody just because I do this. Y'all could do it too if you want to, but you're too proud and you're too broken by academia and you're too in your own head about intellect and style that you can't just hear what's supposed to be built. And so I think that's interesting. He did, however, take a lot of credit for other people's work because he would sort of do these loose sketches and his process was pretty intuitive.
为那个设计过程邀功。他将其视为一种任何人都可以利用的直觉形式，而且更多的建筑师应该利用它。他认为，我想他……好吧，他说：“你知道，我比所有人都强，只是因为我这样做。如果你们愿意，你们也可以做到，但你们太骄傲了，被学术界破坏得太厉害了，你们在智力和风格上太纠结于自己的头脑，以至于你们无法听到本该被建造的东西。”所以我认为这很有趣。然而，他确实为别人的工作邀功，因为他会做这些松散的草图，而且他的过程相当直观。
His draftsman and his construction workers a lot of the time that the tradesmen they would just sort of fill in the patterns like he expected them to do that we don't know exactly how much especially his larger projects of the tiny minute details he did by hand because he taught them how to make these patterns and then they did them he didn't pay his people very well, and he didn't credit them. He took credit for the building, even though they were doing a lot of it. So he didn't take credit for the process.
他的绘图员和建筑工人在很多时候，那些技工，他们只是会填补图案，就像他期望他们做的那样。我们不知道他到底有多少，尤其是他那些大型项目中细微的细节，是他亲手做的，因为他教他们如何制作这些图案，然后他们就做了。他没有给他的员工很好的报酬，也没有给他们署名。他为建筑邀功，尽管他们做了很多工作。所以他没有为过程邀功。
He thought that anyone could just hear this intuition and do it, but he did take credit for other people doing his process, if that makes sense. So one of the ways that his process is articulated that I think is just gorgeous, Taliesin was one of the houses that he built. There's a fire and a murder, and then he goes into a period of mourning, and then later in life he goes back to it. He redoes the house, designs it again, and then now it's like an architectural school.
他认为任何人都可以听到这种直觉并做到这一点，但他确实为别人执行他的过程而邀功，如果这说得通的话。所以，他阐述过程的方式之一，我认为简直太美了，塔里埃森（Taliesin）是他建造的房子之一。那里发生了一场火灾和谋杀，然后他进入了一段哀悼期，后来在生命后期他又回到了那里。他重做了房子，再次设计了它，现在它就像一所建筑学校。
I don't know if they still do it on site. I think they ran out of money. I'm not really sure what the Franklin Wright Foundation's doing, but for a while during his life and after his death, Taliesin was in architecture school. And so one of the, this is something he wrote himself, but this is one of the lessons from that. It was teaching the people how to do architecture, do design. So this is Frank Lloyd Wright writing to the students.
我不知道他们是否还在现场这样做。我想他们没钱了。我不太确定弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特基金会（Franklin Wright Foundation）在做什么，但在他生前和死后的一段时间里，塔里埃森是一所建筑学校。所以其中一个……这是他自己写的，但这是其中的教训之一。它是在教人们如何做建筑，做设计。所以这是弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特写给学生的。
Prepare a geometric study of any Wisconsin wildflower, endeavoring to get the essence of its inherent character. Organize this pattern into a design structured upon a unit system, and strive to establish a grammar which will be inseparable consequence of the design and element and unit system. Grammatical pattern must be consistently of the same source, of the same direction of from that source and on a separate overlay isolate a geometric unit system in linear pattern only know the common name of the wildflower and then bring a few of those flowers to class every design worth considering as a work of art must have a grammar of its own and grammar in this sense means the same thing in any construction whether it be of words or of
准备一份任何威斯康星州野花的几何研究，努力抓住其内在特征的精髓。将这种图案组织成一个基于单位系统的结构化设计，并努力建立一种语法，这将是设计、元素和单位系统的必然结果。语法图案必须始终来自同一个源头，来自该源头的同一个方向，并在一个单独的覆盖层上，仅用线性图案隔离出一个几何单位系统。只知道野花的通用名称，然后带几朵花到课堂上。每一个值得作为艺术品考虑的设计都必须有其自己的语法，而这里的语法在任何结构中都意味着同样的事情，无论是文字的，还是
stone or of wood it is the shape relationship between the various elements that enter into the constitution of the thing your work must be consistently grammatical for it to be understood as a work of art so i'm going to stop for a second here he's saying that you have to be able to have a consistent system with which you listen to all parts of something if it's really going to be art. If you're not doing that, you're just repeating a style or a fad if the tradition's 100 years old, or if it's just what's in vogue that summer. It's not design because you're just copying something. You're not hearing something. So back to Wright back to rights sheet grammar may be deduced from some plant that has appealed to me as a certain property in line or form of the sumac
石头的，还是木头的。它是构成事物的各种元素之间的形状关系。你的作品必须始终符合语法，才能被理解为艺术品。所以我在这里停一下，他是在说，如果你真的想让它成为艺术，你必须能够拥有一个一致的系统，用它来倾听某事物的各个部分。如果你没有这样做，你只是在重复一种风格或时尚，如果这种传统已经有100年了，或者如果它只是那个夏天流行的东西。那不是设计，因为你只是在抄袭某样东西。你没有在倾听某样东西。所以回到赖特，回到赖特的语法表，可以从某种吸引我的植物中推导出来，作为酸模（sumac）线条或形式的某种属性，
i used in the dana house in springfield and the motif is adhered throughout the building all my planning was devised on a properly proportional unit system i found that this would keep all to scale ensuring consistent proportion through the design, which became like a tapestry. A consistent fabric woven of interdependent related units, however various, they invariably, it appears in organic architecture as a visible feature in the fabric of the design, ensuring unity of proportion, the harmony of texture is thus with the scale of all parts within the complete ensemble. Let us learn to see within at least far enough to grasp essential patterns and all created things. Method and creation will come
我用在了斯普林菲尔德的达纳住宅（Dana House）中，并且这个母题贯穿了整个建筑。我所有的规划都是在一个适当比例的单位系统上设计的。我发现这将使一切保持比例，确保整个设计的一致比例，这变得像挂毯一样。一种由相互依存的相关单位编织而成的一致织物，无论多么多样，它们总是以有机建筑的形式作为设计织物中的可见特征出现，确保比例的统一，纹理的和谐，从而与完整集合中所有部分的尺度相协调。让我们学会向内看，至少要看得足够远，以掌握所有创造物中的基本图案。方法和创造将
freely to him who learns to see in the abstract. Study the geometry that is the idea of every form. A quail, a snail, a shell, a fish. Take for analysis the more simple, obvious things first, and then take the texture of the trees. Learn the essential patterns that make the oak and distinguish it from the essential pattern that makes the pine, and then make new new ones try after this the curling vine flowing water or the curving sand and then try the flowers the butterflies and bees and a chrysanthemum is easy a rock or a rose is difficult and I do not mean to take the obvious surface effects that differentiate each but to go within and find the essential geometry of pattern that each but to go within and find the
自由地来到那些学会抽象地看的人身上。研究几何，那是每种形式的理念。鹌鹑、蜗牛、贝壳、鱼。先分析更简单、更明显的东西，然后分析树木的纹理。学习构成橡树并将其与构成松树的基本图案区分开来的基本图案，然后制作新的……尝试在此之后，卷曲的藤蔓、流动的河水或弯曲的沙子，然后尝试花朵、蝴蝶和蜜蜂，菊花很容易，岩石或玫瑰很难。我不是指采取区分每一个的明显表面效果，而是要深入内部，找到赋予每一个特征的本质几何图案，而那对于想要找到方法并获得合法效果的建筑师来说是适当的研究。尝试这种方法，并逐渐训练你观察的力量，耐心地达到你自然地看到这种图案元素和一切事物的地步。弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特。所以他在这里说的核心是，他就像是说，不要只是画
essential geometry of pattern that gives character to each and that is the proper study for an architect who would find a method and get legitimate effects try this method and gradually discipline your power to see get patiently to the point where you naturally see this element of pattern and everything frankly right so the heart of what he's saying there is he's like don't just draw get patiently to the point where you naturally see this element of pattern in everything. Frank Lloyd Wright. So the heart of what he's saying there is he's like, don't just draw the thing as a pattern because it isn't. Listen to the thing, even if it's a rock, even if it's a rose, and try and look up the tiny pieces of what make that thing itself.
把东西当作图案，因为它不是。倾听那个东西，即使它是一块岩石，即使它是一朵玫瑰，并试着找出使那个东西成为它自己的微小部分。
So don't take it and make a pattern out of the shape of the rose. Listen to the pattern that is making of the rose. Listen to the pattern that is making up the rose and then draw that. You know, take everything as a part of a small part, see the pattern that makes it up, and then the larger pattern that it is a part of. And that's very much how we saw the structure. It was this thing that was in between the natural world and the world of the human. And also, you know, this sense of time, timelessness, that you were listening to something older to predict what was going to happen in the future. That if you were just chasing the fad that was around you, it was going to be outdated.
所以不要把它拿走，用玫瑰的形状做一个图案。倾听正在制造玫瑰的图案。倾听正在制造玫瑰的图案，然后画出那个。你知道，把一切都当作一个小部分，看到构成它的图案，然后看到它所属的更大图案。这非常像他看待结构的方式。它是介于自然世界和人类世界之间的东西。而且，你知道，这种时间感、永恒感，即你是在倾听更古老的东西来预测未来会发生什么。如果你只是在追逐你周围的时尚，它很快就会过时。
But if you looked at the way that the natural world and people had always kind of eternally moved and functioned, and you brought that into style that that style would be timeless and i think you can see examples on the if you look at the blog article of people doing this have a picture of the real plant and then i have a picture of people who did this assignment that went through his school what they drew um and it's neat, um, to see how that works. It's hard to explain what he's saying there, but I think it's incredibly profound. You know, like I can, I can hear a lot of things in Frank Lloyd Wright's thought process. Um, there's definitely a lot of, um, Plato and a little bit of Aristotle.
但如果你观察自然世界和人们一直以来永恒移动和运作的方式，并将其带入风格中，那么这种风格将是永恒的。我认为如果你看博客文章，你可以看到人们这样做的例子，我有真实植物的照片，然后我有通过他的学校完成这个作业的人的照片，他们画了什么……这很棒，看到它是如何工作的。很难解释他在那里说什么，但我认为这极其深刻。你知道，就像我能，我能在弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特的思维过程中听到很多东西。嗯，绝对有很多，嗯，柏拉图和一点点亚里士多德。
Like he's kind of into forms and into this theory of like an absolute truth. And you kind of hear that in his writing. He never mentions Jung. He mentions Japan all the time. He really likes this one scholar who does a lot of work with Japan. And then he gets really into Japanese art and culture. But as far as I know, I mean, I think Wright stayed as far away from psychology as he could. He probably encountered Freud just because that was more in the water.
就像他有点沉迷于形式和这种绝对真理的理论。你可以在他的写作中听到这一点。他从不提到荣格。他一直提到日本。他真的很喜欢这位对日本做过大量研究的学者。然后他真的迷上了日本的艺术和文化。但据我所知，我的意思是，我认为赖特尽可能远离心理学。他可能接触过弗洛伊德，因为那更多是在当时的环境中。
But I don't think he ever came across anything like Jung or archetypes. I've never seen him mention anything, not just say that he read it. It's not just that he doesn't. I never found any place where somebody said he read young or he said something about young I'm more that when you read his writing about places where Jungian ideas would come up You don't see any of that in his thinking so I don't think he ever encountered it A lot of times and I haven't read everything that right wrote But a lot of times I think when someone is talking about something, you can tell not
但我认为他从未遇到过像荣格或原型这样的东西。我从未见过他提到任何东西，不仅仅是说他读过它。不仅仅是他没有。我从未找到任何地方有人说他读过荣格，或者他说过关于荣格的话。更多的是，当你阅读他关于荣格思想可能出现的领域的写作时，你在他的思想中看不到任何这些东西，所以我认为他从未接触过它。很多时候，我并没有读过赖特写的所有东西，但很多时候我认为当某人在谈论某事时，你可以看出不是
their influences, but you can tell based on their vocabulary and the way they organize ideas, what kind of thinkers they've encountered and how they're that's affected their thinking, even if they're not aware of it. Um, I don't see that in right. So I don't think that he knew who he was. Um, you can also look, if you Google or look up, um, Seguero forms, that's my favorite piece of stained glass. It's a pattern that Wright
他们的影响，但你可以根据他们的词汇和他们组织思想的方式，看出他们遇到过什么样的思想家，以及这如何影响了他们的思维，即使他们自己没有意识到。嗯，我在赖特身上看不到这一点。所以我认为他不知道他是谁。嗯，你也可以看，如果你谷歌或查找，嗯，仙人掌（Saguaro）形式，那是我最喜欢的彩色玻璃作品。那是一个图案，赖特
made. It's also in one of our therapists, Christy Woods office on a blanket. Um, her right, her office is very frankly, right. Inspired. There's some architecture stuff on the walls and then there's some, you know, arts and crafts furniture. Um, so Wright was an outsider artist and he believed that true architectural genius came from subjective experience you feeling something and your intuition and this innate understanding of environment and communication it didn't come from education it didn't come from academics that put him at huge odds with a lot of other architects who wanted to stand on all of the well i have a phd from Beaux Arts University or whatever.
制作的。它也在我们的一位治疗师克里斯蒂·伍兹（Christy Woods）办公室的毯子上。嗯，她的赖特，她的办公室非常有弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特的灵感。墙上有一些建筑的东西，然后有一些，你知道，工艺美术家具。嗯，所以赖特是一位局外人艺术家，他认为真正的建筑天才来自主观体验，你感受到的东西，你的直觉，以及对环境和交流的这种天生理解。它不是来自教育，它不是来自学术界。这使他与许多其他想要站在所有“嗯，我有布杂艺术大学的博士学位”之类的东西上的建筑师产生了巨大的分歧。
Or Beaux Arts. Some people say Beaux Arts. I don't know what's right. I know I don't really like the style very much at all. But a ton of these people at the time were trying to replicate these old patterns. And they had, you know, you had to go all the way through, you know, French New Empire and Queen Anne style. And all these styles going back to the ancient Greeks and it was all about the style. It wasn't really about the structure,
或者布杂艺术（Beaux Arts）。有些人说布杂艺术。我不知道什么是对的。我知道我一点也不喜欢这种风格。但当时有大量的人试图复制这些旧图案。而且他们有，你知道，你必须经历，你知道，法国新帝国风格和安妮女王风格。以及所有这些追溯到古希腊人的风格，这完全是关于风格的。它不是真正关于结构，
but it was about the kind of, you know, I don't want to say style again, but the way that these buildings were decorated was what they thought was important, not what the buildings really were. They were just sort of repeating older forms and Wright didn't like that. So he drops out of university.
但它是关于那种，你知道，我不想再说风格了，但这些建筑装饰的方式是他们认为重要的，而不是建筑本身是什么。他们只是在重复旧的形式，而赖特不喜欢那样。所以他从大学退学了。
He can't complete it. I don't think at that time you even needed an architecture license. I think if somebody paid you to build a building, you could just do it. I don't know how that worked, but I know he didn't even have a degree. And if he had stayed in college, he probably would never have been on, been gone on to do the architect that he did. Um, he, he's, he wanted to get people who had not yet been corrupted by academia and then teach them his process of listening and turning on intuition.
他无法完成它。我不认为在那个时候你甚至需要建筑执照。我想如果有人付钱让你盖房子，你就可以直接盖。我不知道那是怎么运作的，但我知道他甚至没有学位。如果他留在大学里，他可能永远不会去成为他那样的建筑师。嗯，他，他，他想找那些还没有被学术界腐蚀的人，然后教他们他的倾听和开启直觉的过程。
And he felt strongly that when your ego was very entrenched in intellect and thinking, and you were puffed up with all of that, you just couldn't get it out of your head. It kind of broke people and they weren't able to hear this thing that was just an eight and precious and available to everybody who had ears to hear it so you know his disdain for academia um puts him at odds with a lot of people he gets in a lot of fights uh he saw those institutions as being very prohibitive for the profession moving in a good direction and And he created buildings that were not only functional, but they were supposed to contribute to the overall well-being and happiness of the occupant.
他强烈地感觉到，当你的自我非常根深蒂固于智力和思考，并且你被所有这些东西冲昏了头脑时，你就是无法把它从脑子里赶走。它有点破坏了人们，他们无法听到这种天生、珍贵且对所有有耳朵去听的人都可用的东西。所以，你知道，他对学术界的蔑视，使他与许多人产生了分歧。他卷入了许多争斗，他认为那些机构对职业向好的方向发展非常具有阻碍性。他创造的建筑不仅功能齐全，而且旨在促进居住者的整体福祉和幸福。
And he saw those old styles and traditional forms as ways of listening to the Roman Empire and the needs of somebody from the Bronze Age, but not from the person now. And so he saw the traditional floor plan and the ornamentation of popular styles as hindrances to good design that would be meeting somebody where they were
他将那些旧风格和传统形式视为倾听罗马帝国和青铜时代人们需求的方式，而不是倾听现在的人。所以他将传统的平面图和流行风格的装饰视为良好设计的障碍，这些设计本应在人们所处的地方满足他们，
and giving them what they wanted to see, what they wanted to live in, and in the way that they lived. And so a lot of, you know, I talked about this in a couple articles, but there's two schools of architecture. There's the modernists and the classicists. That's kind of the biggest schools where the most fights happen.
并给他们想要看到的东西，他们想要居住的东西，以及他们生活的方式。所以很多，你知道，我在几篇文章中谈到了这一点，但建筑有两个流派。现代主义者和古典主义者。这是最大的流派，也是争斗最多的地方。
And the classicists are repeating historic styles. And then the modernists are trying to throw old styles out and build modernist-like new materials. And so they're saying, well, let's try and you could never. They only built the Parthenon because they didn't have this cool plastic stuff. We could build this crazy shape, um, that they couldn't with stone. And then the traditional architects, the classicists are like, no, the Parthenon's perfect. Your big wibbly, crazy shaped building is ugly. And these schools fight a lot.
古典主义者在重复历史风格。而现代主义者试图抛弃旧风格，用现代材料建造现代主义风格。所以他们说，好吧，让我们尝试，你永远做不到。他们只建造了帕台农神庙，因为他们没有这些酷炫的塑料东西。我们可以建造这种疯狂的形状，嗯，他们用石头做不到。然后传统建筑师，古典主义者说，不，帕台农神庙是完美的。你那巨大的、摇摇晃晃的、形状疯狂的建筑是丑陋的。这些流派争斗很多。
I don't really see Frank Lloydoyd wright as being a part of either of them he always gets lumped in with the modernists because his buildings are not you know terribly traditional and there's not you know there's things like flat roofs that you see in modernist architecture but a lot of the other modernists modernists like le caboussier and all these people like their buildings did not work like even in their lifetime the flat roofs were leaking and they didn't use material very well. They just sort of did crazy stuff just to do it. And Wright's buildings are still there and they still work well.
我并不真正认为弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特是他们中的一员。他总是被归为现代主义者，因为他的建筑不是，你知道，非常传统，而且没有，你知道，有像现代主义建筑中看到的平屋顶之类的东西。但许多其他现代主义者，像勒·柯布西耶（Le Corbusier）和所有这些人，他们的建筑并不好用，即使在他们有生之年，平屋顶也在漏水，而且他们没有很好地利用材料。他们只是为了做而做一些疯狂的事情。而赖特的建筑仍然在那里，而且它们仍然很好用。
And, you know, there aren't know if he is a modernist. Classicists typically hate him. And then modernists don't really see him as anything special but accept him into the movement. I don't see him as a modernist. who is another architect who his stuff he draws these crazy wibbly lines and just goes wild making these weird things but when he does that there there's no thought to how someone's actually going to use this space like when i went to his one of his buildings it's a museum and there's like it's this huge wibbly sheet metal stuff and it's kind of impressive when you're walking up to it because you've never seen
而且，你知道，不知道他是否是现代主义者。古典主义者通常讨厌他。而现代主义者并不真正认为他有什么特别之处，但接受他进入这个运动。我不认为他是一个现代主义者。谁是另一位建筑师，他的东西，他画这些疯狂的摇摇晃晃的线条，只是疯狂地制造这些奇怪的东西，但当他这样做时，没有考虑到有人会如何实际使用这个空间。就像当我去了他的一栋建筑时，那是一个博物馆，有那种巨大的摇摇晃晃的金属板东西，当你走近它时，它有点令人印象深刻，因为你从未见过
anything like this and then you go inside and it's like okay so those wild walls meant that half of this is unusable you know like why didn't you put the air conditioner somewhere where i couldn't see it you know up in the top and hide it or why didn't you so why is half this room at some weird angle where it's using up all your sight and all your room, but no one have like bumper rails because the wall came down at this angle for somebody who is visually impaired because they would walk into the wall and get hurt since your walls are angled so now there's this clunky rail that they're would have to use for their cane to tap on and that's making people trip and over like There's no thought in a lot of modernists. They really just get on AutoCAD or Revit and they draw something nuts. And then they just put rooms in it.
诸如此类的事情，当你走进去时，你会觉得，好吧，那些狂野的墙壁意味着这里有一半空间是无法使用的。你知道，为什么你不把空调放在我看不见的地方，比如放在高处藏起来？或者为什么这个房间的一半要以某种奇怪的角度存在，占用了你所有的视野和空间？但没有人安装防撞栏，因为墙壁是以这种角度倾斜的，对于视障人士来说，他们会撞到墙上受伤。既然你的墙壁是倾斜的，现在就必须安装这种笨重的扶手，让他们用手杖去敲击，但这反而让人绊倒。很多现代主义者根本没有思考。他们只是打开AutoCAD或Revit，画出一些疯狂的东西，然后把房间塞进去。
And there's nothing about how things fit together, how people use space, what the flow is. The sort of archetypal ideas of when somebody walks into a building, their brain is just going to kind of naturally take them to the right. I'm not going to kind of naturally take them to the right. Like, you know, people have these, I'm not going to go terribly into that, but people have like a lot of biases in the way that they use space that are genetic. I mean, they're just inborn. They've done all these studies. There's no reason for it.
关于事物如何组合、人们如何使用空间、动线如何规划，他们完全没有考虑。当一个人走进一栋建筑时，大脑会自然而然地引导他们向右转，这是一种原型理念。我不会深入探讨这个，但人们在使用空间的方式上确实存在很多基因层面的偏见。我的意思是，它们是与生俱来的。人们已经做过所有这些研究，这不需要理由。
It's cross-cultural. It's just, if you build a store one way, people won't know how to use it. And a lot of the modernists like Gary, they don't use any of that stuff. And so the buildings, you know, one, they don't really hold up. They just are so expensive to work on. And, you know, his crazy shape isn't to be like, Frank Gary's crazy shape isn't to be like, okay, so the water is going to fall off here. So I better put another angle here so that
这是跨文化的。如果你以某种方式建造一家商店，人们就会不知道如何使用它。很多像盖里（Gary）这样的现代主义者，根本不使用这些东西。所以这些建筑，第一，它们并不耐用。维护起来非常昂贵。而且，你知道，他那些疯狂的形状并不是为了，弗兰克·盖里（Frank Gehry）那些疯狂的形状并不是为了，好吧，水会从这里流下来，所以我最好在这里加一个角度，以便
I pull water away from the building. Because if I pull water away from the building, then it's going to last longer because it's not going to rust or it's not going to leak. And so this is visually neat, but the purpose is to manage. No, he just makes a giant sheet metal cube and water pools up and somebody makes it out of steel. But there's not any thought other than self-indulgence. And like one of the things that Frank Gehry's house, if you ever see it, he has like this giant cube and then glass wall in the back of the house. And somebody like Wright, who's listening to a site for like a year, sometimes before he would even draw anything because he wanted to see how all the seasons affected it and the storms and the wind and how the family lived. And they're putting a ton of thought into really hearing
我能把水引离建筑。因为如果我把水引离建筑，它就会更持久，因为它不会生锈，也不会漏水。所以这在视觉上很整洁，但目的是为了管理。不，他只是做了一个巨大的金属立方体，水积聚在那里，然后有人用钢材把它做出来。除了自我放纵，没有任何思考。就像弗兰克·盖里的房子，如果你见过的话，他有一个巨大的立方体，房子后面有一面玻璃墙。而像赖特（Wright）这样的人，在画任何东西之前，有时会花一年时间倾听场地，因为他想看看四季、风暴、风以及家庭生活是如何影响它的。他们投入了大量的思考去真正倾听
what is needed from the people and hearing what is needed or reflective of the nature um the reason that frank gary did that addition to his house is that he was just shaving and then he like looked up at the corner of his bathroom and he was like i wish natural light came through there what if it came through there so he got a hammer basically and just started beating his wall and ripped a thing out and then was like that looks kind of cool i like that you know that's neat and then he left the structural boards there but ripped all the plaster wall out and then put like a sheet of had people come in and put a sheet of glass there and then was like okay out here what could i well just put like a giant cube and it can also be the greenhouse will be made of glass. So like one of the walls coming off of his back bathroom, even though his house is more of a traditional architecture thing that he added onto, it was like this crazy glass wall.
人们需要什么，以及倾听什么是必要的，或者反映自然。嗯，弗兰克·盖里对他房子进行扩建的原因是，他当时正在刮胡子，然后他抬头看了看浴室的角落，心想，我希望自然光能从那里照进来，如果它从那里照进来会怎样？于是他拿了一把锤子，基本上就开始敲打他的墙，把东西拆掉，然后觉得，看起来挺酷的，我喜欢那个，你知道，那很整洁。然后他留下了结构板，但拆掉了所有的石膏墙，然后放了一块，让人进来装了一块玻璃，然后心想，好吧，外面这里，我能做什么？就放一个巨大的立方体，它也可以是温室，由玻璃制成。所以，他后浴室的一面墙，尽管他的房子更多是传统建筑，但他加建的部分，就像这面疯狂的玻璃墙。
But that's how he got there. He just literally was shaving and was like, I kind of want to see light. I'm going to knock a hole in the wall. I mean, very impulsive and self-indulgent and not a thoughtful guy. You know, um, you know, he can talk about it later, but that's how he did it.
但这就是他得出结果的方式。他当时真的只是在刮胡子，心想，我有点想看到光。我要在墙上敲个洞。我的意思是，非常冲动和自我放纵，不是一个深思熟虑的人。你知道，嗯，你知道，他以后可以谈论它，但这就是他做这件事的方式。
Um, you know, and somebody like a director like Zack Snyder, I'm going away to the woods here and away from the article, the article on the blog might give you a better overlay of information, but a director like Zack Snyder, who I don't really like at all, um,
嗯，你知道，像扎克·施奈德（Zack Snyder）这样的导演，我这里要跑题了，偏离了文章，博客上的文章可能会给你提供更好的信息叠加，但像扎克·施奈德这样的导演，我一点也不喜欢，嗯，
who nothing feels intentional in the movies. It just feels like he's sitting there being like, well, that would be cool. This would be cool, too. Well, this should happen next. And nothing happens. There's no character development. It doesn't do anything original. It doesn't build to anything.
他的电影里没有任何东西让人感觉是有意为之的。感觉就像他坐在那里说，嗯，那会很酷。这个也会很酷。嗯，接下来应该发生这个。但什么也没发生。没有角色发展。它没有做任何原创的东西。它没有构建任何东西。
It's just somebody grabbing random crap. And that is not, you know, I don't want to paint with too broad a brush. It's an enormous amount of architects. But that's what I see in a lot of modernism that I don't want to paint with too broad a brush. It's an enormous amount of architects, but that's what I see in a lot of modernism that I don't see in Wright. And that's why I have a hard time just putting Wright in that movement. I don't know that that's what he is.
这只是某人在抓取随机的垃圾。这不是，你知道，我不想一概而论。有大量的建筑师。但这正是我在很多现代主义中看到的，我不想一概而论。有大量的建筑师，但这正是我在很多现代主义中看到的，而在赖特身上我没看到。这就是为什么我很难把赖特归入那个运动。我不知道他是否属于那一类。
But again, he does blow up all these classical principles. If he doesn't break them, he could never have done the cantilevered structure that made Falling Waters so famous. That does not come from classical design. It's a totally modern process. He would never have been able to use all the asymmetry he used. I mean, that's another reason that his buildings look so modern is that they're not symmetrical.
但话说回来，他确实打破了所有这些古典原则。如果他不打破它们，他就永远无法做出让流水别墅（Falling Waters）如此出名的悬臂结构。那不是来自古典设计。这是一个完全现代的过程。他永远无法使用他所使用的所有不对称性。我的意思是，这也是他的建筑看起来如此现代的另一个原因，因为它们不是对称的。
He didn't have a problem about making everything mirror the way that Renaissance and Roman architecture does. does and you know he based a lot of things though like a classical architect would on these mathematical formulas like the golden mean and the golden ratio and these concepts of mathematical proportion that come from nature that are used in Renaissance mathematics and architecture and to a certain extent in Greek and Roman architecture. But what's kind of funny to me is like they always make fun of Wright, the classicist, for not being symmetrical, that his buildings will not have this symmetry. But then you look at like the golden mean or the golden ratio like, it isn't symmetrical. It sort of opens
他对于让一切都像文艺复兴和罗马建筑那样镜像化没有问题。而且你知道，他确实像古典建筑师一样，基于这些数学公式，如黄金分割和黄金比例，以及这些源于自然的数学比例概念，这些概念被用于文艺复兴时期的数学和建筑，并在一定程度上用于希腊和罗马建筑。但对我来说有趣的是，他们总是嘲笑赖特这位古典主义者不讲对称，说他的建筑没有这种对称性。但当你看看黄金分割或黄金比例时，它是不对称的。它有点像
like a shell. So sometimes he's actually modeling the patterns that Renaissance architecture was built on more accurately, maybe than classical traditions, which is, is kind of this weird thing. Like, um, you know, the classicists want to go back to Greek and Roman architecture. Uh, and I think Wright wanted to go further back than that. He wanted to go all the way back to the early spiritual heart of mankind and the early spiritual patterns and, and bits of nature. He wasn't trying to go back to, they wanted to keep everything in this one point.
贝壳一样打开。所以有时他实际上比古典传统更准确地模拟了文艺复兴建筑所建立的模式，这是一种奇怪的事情。就像，嗯，你知道，古典主义者想回到希腊和罗马建筑。嗯，我认为赖特想回到比那更远的地方。他想一直回到人类早期的精神核心，早期的精神模式和自然的碎片。他不是想回到，他们想把一切都保持在这一点上。
And Wright was not really reaching for the future. He was also reaching for the past, but I think he was reaching further back than a lot of classical architects that only wanted to stop with, you know, the Western architecture, starting with Greece and Rome. And Wright was trying to hear something that was more profound and probably more ancient. He wanted to make architecture about the people of today, not traditions of the past, but he didn't want it to just be about a myopic sense of the people of today. He wanted it to be about the future, but he didn't want it to just be about a myopic sense of the people of today. He wanted it to be about the future too. And if you're trying to define that higher power thing that I keep talking about in Wright's work, that is it, I think, is that it wasn't just for the family that he was building it for. It was for the family when they were 20 years older than the
而赖特并不是真的在追求未来。他也在追求过去，但我认为他追求得比许多只想停留在西方建筑（从希腊和罗马开始）的古典建筑师更远。赖特试图倾听一些更深刻、可能更古老的东西。他想让建筑关乎今天的人们，而不是过去的传统，但他不想让它仅仅关乎对今天人们的短视感。他想让它关乎未来，但他不想让它仅仅关乎对今天人们的短视感。他也想让它关乎未来。如果你试图定义我一直在赖特作品中谈论的那种更高力量的东西，我想就是这个，它不仅仅是为了他为其建造的那个家庭。它是为了当他们比现在的客户大20岁时，当他们去世，他们的家人住在这栋建筑里，他们的大家庭，当未来有人遇到这些结构时。这不仅仅是做人们现在想要的东西。这是给他们一份他们未来会想要的礼物。我在现代建筑中看不到太多这样的东西。它往往老化得很快。所以我认为赖特的重点在于一种深刻而深远的直觉或倾听能力。而且，你知道，直觉的根源在于看到事物中非常复杂模式的能力。所以最好的音乐家在声音上做到这一点，而最好的
clients that he had right now, when they were dead and their families were living in the building, their extended families, when there were people who were encountering these structures in the future. It wasn't just about doing the thing that people wanted right now. It was about giving them this gift that they would want in the future. And I don't see a ton of that in modern architecture. It tends to age pretty quickly. So the takeaway that I think is the point of Wright is really a deep and profound intuition or ability to listen. And, you know, intuition is at its root, the ability to see very complex patterns within something. And so the best musicians do that sonically, while the best
治疗师通过分析某人的情绪、家庭结构、身份和言语模式来做到这一点。作为直觉者，你在寻找模式。赖特的建筑是一种半无意识地调谐到自然世界、人类生活以及我们的艺术和精神抱负的模式。所以当你参观赖特的空间时，你仍然可以听到他在倾听我们已经忘记如何去听的模式。你知道，赖特的房子通常像贝壳一样包裹着家庭，你知道，或者像这种拥抱一样，环绕着房子的家庭区域。与需要向街道传达
therapists do that through analysis of somebody's emotions and their family structure and their identity and their speech patterns. You're looking for patterns as an intuitive. Wright's architecture was a semi-unconscious tuning into the patterns of the natural world and of human life and about our artistic and our spiritual aspirations. And so when you visit Wright's spaces, you can still hear him listening to patterns that we've kind of forgotten how to hear. You know, Wright's houses often wrap around the family like a shell, you know, or arms like in this kind of hug, the family areas of the house. And unlike Victorian buildings that needed to communicate
权力和阶级的维多利亚式建筑不同，你知道，大院子，社会地位，院子的起源是我赚了足够的钱，不需要用我的土地来种食物，我只是要种草。而且你知道，你放在柱子和房子外面的很多细节和装饰，是为了说明你是谁。赖特认为这不再相关了。你知道，他的建筑保护家庭免受街道的影响，然后像贝壳一样向后院开放。在赖特的家中，房子的焦点是壁炉和家庭活动室
power and class towards the street, you know, big yard, social standing, the origin of the yard is that I make enough money that I don't have to use my land to grow food, I'm just gonna grow grass. And you know, a lot of the detail and ornamentation you put onto things like columns and the outside of the house, it was about saying who you were. Wright sees that as not relevant anymore. You know, his buildings shelter the family from the street and then they open towards the backyard like a shell. In Wright's homes, the focus of the house is on the hearth and the family room
以及中央花园或水池。面向街道的墙壁去除了细节，他的房子通常有这种极简主义的岩石或砖块外观面向街道。他做了很多房子，所以这对所有房子来说通常都是真的，但它们确实因地理位置而异。你知道，草原住宅看起来与你所能复兴的非常不同，但它们确实因地理位置而异。你知道，草原住宅看起来与你所能复兴的非常不同，但它们确实没有相同的平面图，但有相同的模式，平面图是建立在这些模式上的。它们通常包括某种水或岩石护城河，通常有小的狭缝窗，有一座小桥通向房子。在那里，我把它们看作是对欧洲城堡的一种重新构想，是
and the central garden or a pool a lot of the time. The street facing walls are stripped of detail and his houses often have this minimalist rock or brick exteriors facing the street. He did a lot of houses, so this is generally true of all of them, but they do vary where he built them geographically. You know, prairie homes look very different than you can revival, but they do vary where he built them geographically. You know, prairie homes look very different than you can revival, but they do have not the same floor plan, but the same pattern the floor plan is built on. And they often include kind of water or rock moats and usually small slit windows with a little bridge that goes to the, to the house. And, and there I see them as kind of a re-imagining of the European castle is the
文明的中心，但在美国环境中，规模较小。所以他在说，你知道，这些建筑，嗯，你知道，社会过去围绕着国王或社会等级制度，但现在美国社会围绕着中产阶级和家庭。我认为这个信息在他建造房屋的方式中很重要。他的家是他最有趣的建筑之一。所以，如果赖特传记中有什么事情发生在他生命中足够早的时候，能为他个人生活的疯狂提供某种心理学解释，那可能就是他父母那场充满争议的离婚，有些人觉得这让他感到痛苦。而且，这种早期精神、情感和家庭中心的丧失，可能通过让他想要
center of civilization, but in an American setting and on a smaller scale. So he's saying, you know, these buildings, um, you know, society used to center around a king or a social hierarchy, but now American society centers around the middle class and the family. And that message I think is important in the way that he built homes. His homes are some of his most interesting buildings. So if there's anything in Wright's biography that occurred early enough in his life to provide some kind of psychological explanation for just the madness of his personal life, it probably would be the contentious divorce of his parents that some people felt like had caused him distress. And it's possible that that early loss of this spiritual emotional and familial center in his life informed his career trajectory by you know making him want
将建筑职业重新定位在一种培育性的母性社区建筑空间，以及一个更大的精神或情感中心周围，从而影响了他的职业轨迹。他觉得建筑失去了中心。而且很可能因为他，你知道，很多时候我们的艺术家，这种青春的投射，嗯，是因为他小时候发生的事情而那样做的。所以，你知道，我认为好的设计是一种拟像，你知道，它是一种没有原型的复制品，或者被复制了太多次，以至于它的起源不如复制过程中的变化那样可见。而且它是，你知道，好的设计是某种东西的复制品
to re-center the profession of architecture around the idea of a nurturing maternal community built space and also a greater spiritual or emotional center. He felt like architecture had lost its center. And it's possible that because he, you know, a lot of times our artists, this projection of youth, um, was doing that because of something that happened to him as a kid. And so, you know, I think good design is a kind of simulacrum, you know, it's a simulacrum as a copy without an original or something that's been copied so many times that its origins are not as visible as the changes through the copying. And it is, you know, good design is a copy of something
它是无意识的，深深植根于我们内心，它不是来自自然，而是来自我们内心对自然的反映。我们无法处理，来自我们内心对自然的反映。我们无法处理自然的外部现实或我们内化它的内部现实，它们变成了我们投射到艺术中的东西。所以我们的艺术中心往往来自早期的童年创伤。阴影投射变成了，你知道，我们在职业上卓越，但在人际关系上失败的地方，它变成了我们在无意识直觉上擅长的地方。但很多时候，那种无意识的直觉从未以一种我们可以将其有意识地带入个人生活的方式实现。所以我们重复并创造我们的创伤，直到我们面对它。我希望我们能说大多数艺术家面对了他们的创伤，但不幸的是，大多数人选择不去这些可怕的地方。嗯，
that is unconscious and deep within us that does not come from nature, but it comes from a reflection of nature within ourselves. And our inability to deal comes from a reflection of nature within ourselves. And our inability to deal with the outer realities of nature or the inner realities of the way that we internalize it, they become what we project into art. So often our artistic center comes from an early childhood pain. And the shadow projection becomes, you know, where we've, where we are excellent professionally, but we fail interpersonally and it becomes where we excel with unconscious intuition. But a lot of times that unconscious intuition is never actualized in a way where we can bring it consciously into our personal lives. And so we repeat and we create our trauma until we face it. And I wish that we could say that most artists face their trauma, but unfortunately most people choose not to go into these scary places. Um,
你知道，我说了很多，你知道，人们来接受治疗的原因有很多，但在所有这些原因之下，我们实际上只做了一个选择。那就是，我是否要进入那个可怕的事情？我觉得如果我回到那里，我会死。我是否面对它？如果我面对它，我是成长了，还是我只是选择逃避、忽视并终生逃离它，或者为此责怪别人等等？我认为赖特在个人成长方面确实失败了，但他在建筑师方面确实成长了很多。但可悲的是，他的很多无意识，他的直觉仍然是无意识的。这对很多艺术家来说都是真的。我希望我能说这对很多治疗师来说不是真的，但，我，你知道，我希望我能说这对很多
you know, I've said a lot, you know, there's a lot of reasons why people come into therapy, but underneath all of them, there's really only one choice that we're making. It's, do I go into the scary thing? And I feel like if I go back there, I'll die. And do I face that? And if I face it, do I grow or do I just kind of choose to avoid and ignore and run from that my whole life or blame other people for it or whatever? And I think Wright definitely fails to grow as a person, but he does grow a lot as an architect. But sadly, a lot of his unconscious, his intuition remains unconscious. And that's true of a lot of artists. I wish that I could say it wasn't true of a lot of therapists, but's, I, you know, I wish that I could say it wasn't true of a
治疗师来说不是真的，但事实确实如此，我必须在自己身上对抗这种倾向。嗯，你知道，所有的治疗师都应该接受治疗，我认为治疗变得有害的地方在于有人说，好吧，我已经完成了我所有的工作。这就是我好起来的方式。所以这就是你必须好起来的方式。这就是治疗可能成为问题的地方。嗯，因为你，你，你还没有处理好某件事，你正试图给别人你需要的药。你看到了那种痴迷，一个治疗师真的想让病人，病人不会这样做。就像，好吧，好吧，也许他们想。有一种能量。你看到了。我认为这绝对是赖特。但永恒的艺术和建筑
lot of therapists, but it is, I have to fight that tendency in myself. Um, you know, all therapists should be in therapy and where I think therapy becomes damaging is where somebody says, well, I've done all my work. This is how I got better. So that's how you have to get better. And that's where therapy can become problem. Um, because you, you, you haven't dealt with something and you're trying to give other people the medicine that you need. And you see that obsession where a therapist like really want the patient to, the patient won't do this. It's like, well, okay, well, maybe they want to. There's an energy. And you see that. And I think that's definitely who Wright was. But timeless art and architecture
与心理学是分不开的，因为它要求我们放下个人的自我，与我们集体人性深处的东西接触。所以我们不是随机设计这些东西的。我的意思是，也许弗兰克·盖里是这样。我不认为赖特是这样。我对盖里的批评不是说东西看起来不酷。而是如果你在不同的一天去找他，你会得到一栋完全不同的建筑。他坐下来，没有任何思考，然后画出一些有点疯狂的东西。而且没有，它不服务于任何更伟大的东西。嗯，除了这是一个我可以建造的疯狂东西之外，没有其他过程。
is inseparable from psychology because it requires us to set our individual ego aside and make contact with something that is deep inside our collective humanity. And so we don't design this stuff at random. I mean, maybe Frank Gehry did. I don't think Wright does. My criticism with Gehry is that it's not that the stuff doesn't look cool. It's that if you had come to him on a different day, you would have gotten a completely different building. He sits down without any thought, and then he draws something that's kind of crazy. And there isn't, it's not in service of anything greater. Um, there's not a process other than this is kind of a crazy thing that I can build.
你看看艺术，对吧。你认为如果你有《黑衣人》里的那种记忆消除器，你把他带回同一个场地，面对同一个家庭，他会想出一栋几乎一样的建筑。你知道，如果你从他的记忆中删除了这个，然后让他重新设计，因为他的过程是如此，嗯，深度导向的，它会提取出很多相同的元素。所以，你知道，我们不是在真空中做这些事情，嗯，它们来自我们的心理，这就是为什么我把它放在一个关于心理学的播客和博客上，嗯，关于建筑的东西，我不认为赖特的所有作品都是完美的，但我认为他对建筑在我们生活中所扮演角色的构想是深刻的。你知道，通过将他的结构注入有意义的模式和符号，
And you look at art, right. And you think if you got the little men in black, you know, memory eraser thing, and you brought him back to the same site with the same family he would have come up with a building that was almost the same you know if you deleted this from his memory and then had him design it again because his process was so um depth oriented that it would have pulled up a lot of the same elements and so you know we don't do these things in a vacuum um they come from our psychology which is which is why i'm putting it on a podcast and a blog about psychology um something about architecture and i don't think all of wright's work is perfect but i think his conception of the role that architecture plays in our lives is profound you know by infusing his structures with meaningful patterns and symbols
取自自然和人类文化，赖特超越了纯粹功能的界限。他创造了激发情感并与人类精神深度连接的空间。他将建筑视为人类、自然和形而上学的交汇点，他的建筑设计更像是祭坛，用来容纳他视为神圣的这些力量的相互作用。建筑确实塑造了我们的生活，它确实丰富了我们的体验。无论我们是否注意到，建筑都在影响你，在你一生中大部分时间待在建筑里的任何时刻，它都在帮助你或伤害你。那栋建筑对你有影响，无论你是否知道它在做什么，以及这种影响来自哪里。而我们今天居住的当代建筑，它们仍然在与我们对话。但它们所说的
taken from nature and human culture, Wright transcended the boundaries of mere functionality. He created spaces that stirred emotion and connected deeply with the human spirit. He saw architecture as an intersection of the human, the natural, and the metaphysical, and his buildings were designed more like altars to hold the interplay of these forces he saw as sacred. And architecture does shape our lives and it does enrich our experiences. Whether we notice it or not, architecture is affecting you and it is helping you or harming you at any moment when you are in a building for most of your life. And that building has an effect on you, whether or not you know what it's doing and where that effect comes from. And the contemporary buildings that we inhabit today, they still talk to us. But what they say
现在是有问题的。它们告诉我们，我们是商业交易中可有可无的齿轮，我们所能建造的最临时和可有可无的结构就是我们所应得的。我们把孩子送进这些没有窗户的煤渣砖建筑里，铺着油毡和混凝土地板，地上有排水沟，这样它们就可以被冲洗干净，周围环绕着铁丝网。大多数美国学校建得像监狱。我们把孩子送到那里去学习。但我们送他们进去学习什么呢？你知道，在这个煤渣砖地狱里，你知道，莱昂·克里尔（Leon Krier）是我前段时间在播客上谈到的一位建筑师，嗯，他告诉我的事情之一，我感到很有趣的是，他曾见过，嗯，荣格分析师詹姆斯·霍利斯（James Hollis），他是一位荣格派，嗯，詹姆斯·霍利斯现在已经去世了，但他多年前见过他，他告诉
is now problematic. They tell us that we're disposable cogs on a set of business transactions and that the most temporary and disposable structures that can be built are all we deserve. We send our children into these windowless cinderblock buildings with linoleum and concrete floors and drains on the ground so they can be hosed down and they're encircled by chain link. And most American schools are built like prisons. And we send kids there to learn. But what are we sending them in there to learn you know in this cinder block hell you know leon career was an architect that i talked to a while back um on the podcast and one of the things he told me i got a kick out of was that he had met um the union analyst james hollis at one point he's union uh james hollis is dead now but he had met him years ago and he told
他，嗯，你知道，欧洲办公室的设计是为了让眼睛以这种向上的方式移动，去仰望天堂，建筑的重点就像线条把你向上拉，几乎像教堂一样。而美国办公室的设计带有这种刺眼的荧光灯和这些廉价的吊顶，那种泡沫塑料般的瓷砖，他们放在那里，嗯，这样你就会看向别处，你不得不向下窥视地狱。我一直觉得这很有趣，嗯，因为我真的不喜欢吊顶。我不知道我们为什么同意这样做。而且太多的东西，就像我只是不明白，你知道，就像我看到我女儿在哪里时，我感到非常沮丧
him that uh you know european offices are designed so that the eye moves upwards in this aspirational way to look at heaven and the point of the building like the lines draw you up almost like a church and american offices are designed with this harsh fluorescent lighting and these cheap drop ceilings that styrofoam like tile they put up there um so that you would looked away from it and you had to peer down into hell and i always thought that was funny um because i really do not like drop ceilings i don't know why we ever agreed to do that and so much so much of the stuff like i just don't get you know it's like i was so frustrated when i saw where my daughter was
去上学，我们所在的学校系统应该是很好的。但就像，没有窗户。只有煤渣砖。每个人都说，嗯，这就是60年代和70年代建造一切的方式。就像，看，如果历史上任何时候这是我们建造东西的方式。第一，我们需要永远为此道歉并审视它。我们不需要休息，直到所有这些东西都被纠正。因为我不希望孩子进入这个看起来像他们犯了罪的地方。你知道，我上的小学
going to school and we're in the school system that's supposed to be good. And it's like, there's not windows. It's just cinder blocks. And everyone's like, well, that's just how everything was built in the 60s and 70s. And it's like, look, there was any point in history where this was the way that we built things. One, we need to apologize about that forever and look at it. And we don't need to rest until all of this stuff is corrected. Because I don't want a child to go into this place it looks like they committed a crime you know my elementary school i went to
Shades Cahaba Homewood，它有这些大窗户，它有这些壁灯，它有所有的光。我的意思是，当我想到学校，小学时，我记得的是看着树，就像看着自然，就像看着自然，看着果园，看着天气，当那个人在说话时，感觉就像我在一个社区里，我就像在一个我应该学到好东西的地方。你知道，我的高中建得像一个煤渣砖地狱，我的初中也是。我只记得走进那里的强烈对比，心想，我不想待在这里，这个地方感觉像是在攻击我，感觉像是我做错了什么，感觉这不是一个好地方。我不认为每个人都像我一样意识到这一点，
shades common homewood it had these big windows it had these sconces it had all of this light i mean what i remember when i think of school elementary school was like looking out at trees and like looking out at nature and like looking out at nature and seeing like the orchard and seeing watching the weather while the person was talking and feeling like I was in a community and I was like in a place where I was supposed to learn something good you know my high school was built like a cinder block hellscape and my middle school and I just remember the stark contrast of going in there and being like I don't want to be here this place is feels like an attack on me it feels like I did something wrong it feels like this is not a good place and I don't think everyone is as conscious of that as I was
但我仍然认为这影响了每个人。设计对我们的心理有很大的控制力，无论我们是否在听，我们都在听。而且，你知道，所以当赖特设计时，他倾听自然和人类生活交织模式的和谐。他把这些视觉化地呈现在他设计的空间中。他采用了更广泛的景观自然模式，并让它们在结构中涟漪，你知道，在宏观、中观和微观尺度上。当他打破古典建筑的规则时，这只是为了支持实际功能，或者为了传达地点、环境和目的的更广泛意义。我们生活在一个自然世界中，但我们必须使它部分成为人类的世界。我们也服务于一个更高的目的。我们应该深思熟虑地思考我们想要那个目的是什么。我们
but I still think that affects everyone and design is something that has a pretty big hold on our psychology that we are hearing whether or not we are listening to it. And, you know, so when Wright designed, he listened to the harmony of the intersecting patterns of nature and human life. And he represented these visually across the spaces that he designed. He took broader natural patterns of the landscape and he had them ripple across the structure in, you know, macro, meso, and micro scales. When he broke the rules of classical architecture, it was only in service to support the practical function or to communicate the broader significance of place and setting and purpose. We live in a natural world, but we must make it partially a human one. And we also serve a higher purpose. And we should think mindfully about what we want that purpose to be. Where we
居住的地方改变了我们生活的方式以及我们共同生活的方式。建筑曾经让我们的生活成为艺术。而现在，它是将我们的生活转化为利润过程中的一个事后想法。你在这些结构中感受到了这一点。它们是对你的攻击。它们正在告诉你你到底值多少钱。这就是为什么它们让我像那样生气。这很酷。现在，我们的建筑，它们仍然是祭坛，但它们现在是通往非常黑暗的神的祭坛。你知道，宏大、自我、竞争、等级制度和贪婪是我们正在为其建造寺庙的东西。我们放在城市上的现代符文和象形文字是广告和警告标签，你知道，来自Hobby Lobby的廉价情感，
live changes how we live and how we live together. And architecture used to make our lives art. And now it's an afterthought in this process of turning our lives into a profit. And you feel that in these structures. They are an attack on you. And they're telling you exactly what you're worth. And that's why they make me mad like that. That's cool. Now, our buildings, they're still altars, but they are altars to very dark gods now. You know, grandiosity and ego and competition and hierarchy and greed are what we were building temples to. And the modern runes and hieroglyphs that we put on our cities are advertisements and warning labels and, you know, cheap sentiments from Hobby Lobby,
墙上的装饰，你知道，朋友、恨、家庭，你知道，没有任何东西像赖特试图倾听的那样真实，你知道，某种廉价的情感或趋势。我们需要记住我们更高的目的。你知道，自然世界和发展我们自己的灵魂是我们在这里的原因。我们需要再次信任直觉、创新和自然。当我那样说时，不仅仅是像树叶那样的自然，而是像我们自己的人性那样的自然，我们表现得好像我们已经超越了它，你知道，我们需要能够活在我们的现状和我们的出身中。当我那样说赖特是一个重要的人时，这就是我的意思。这是最好的解释。
wall wraps of, you know, friends, hate, family, you know, not anything that is as real as what Wright was trying to hear, you know, kind of cheap sentiment or trends. And we need to remember our higher purpose. You know, the natural world and developing our own soul is why we're here. And we need to trust intuition and innovation and nature again. And when I say that, and not just the nature like leaves on trees, nature like our own human nature that we act like we've transcended, you know, we need to be able to be present in who we are and where we come from. And when I say that right is an important person, that's what I mean. That's the best explanation.
我写这个是为了回答那些说，为什么是这样？你在他身上看到了什么？这是我所听到的最好的表达，不完美的表达。我真的希望我们的文明能够记住这些模式。它们仍然在那里。如果你花时间，你，你花一点时间去倾听。好了。这就是今天的剧集。如果你有疑问或评论，请给我发电子邮件。我最近在做很多关于设计的事情。我们还做了一个关于椅子的播客，设计的历史和椅子，以及伊姆斯椅（Eames chair）。然后在七月的某个时候，我们将与我的朋友，城市规划师威尔·塞尔曼（Will Selman）坐下来谈谈。他将
I wrote this in answer to people that had said, why is it? What do you see in him? That's the best articulation, imperfect articulation of what I hear. And I really wish that our civilization could remember these patterns. And they are still there. If you take the time and you, you take a moment to listen. All right. That was the episode for today. If you have a question or a comment, please send me an email. I'm doing a lot of stuff about design recently. We also did a podcast on chairs, the history of design and chairs and the Eames chair. And then sometime in July, we're going to sit down with a friend of mine, Will Selman, an urban planner. He's going to
分享他的故事，出版一本书，关于荣格心理学和城市设计的融合，这是一个非常Tabroot Therapy风格的嘉宾。所以我们对此很兴奋。继续关注。我们不会永远做设计。我们只是有点迷上了。但是的，让我知道你的想法。像这个话题，很多话题都是从我收到的问题中策划出来的，并试图思考给你一个深思熟虑的回答。所以如果你有一个，请发送。我确实读了那些。我总是没时间，但我会尽快回复你。非常感谢你的收听。祝你有个愉快的一周。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
share his stories, publishing a book, which is about the fusion of Jungian psychology and urban design, which is a very Tabroot Therapy kind of guest to have. So we're excited for that. Keep checking in. We're not going to do design forever. We've just kind of been on a kick there. But yeah, let me know what you think. Like this topic, a lot of the topics are curated from just questions that I get and try and think about to give you a mindful answer. So if you got one, please send it. I do read those. I am always out of time, but I will get to you as soon as I can. And thank you so much for listening. Have a nice week. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
分享他的故事，并出版了一本关于荣格心理学与城市设计融合的书，这非常符合“塔布鲁特疗法”（Tabroot Therapy）的嘉宾风格。所以我们对此感到非常兴奋。请持续关注。我们不会永远只谈论设计，这只是我们最近的一时兴起。但确实，请让我知道你的想法。像这个话题一样，很多话题都是从我收到的问题中精心挑选出来的，我试着思考并给你一个深思熟虑的回答。所以如果你有任何问题，请发送给我。我确实会阅读这些问题。我总是时间不够，但我会尽快回复你。非常感谢你的收听。祝你度过愉快的一周。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。